so before we talk
about
the various vaccines for code 19
i'd like to talk to you about censorship
given everything you're saying
why did youtube
and other places
censor
discussion
of
ever mectin
well there's a question about why they
say they did it and there's a question
about why they actually did it
now
it is worth mentioning
that youtube is part of a consortium
it is partnered with twitter
facebook reuters ap financial times
washington post
some other notable organizations
and that
this group
has appointed itself
the arbiter of truth
in effect they have decided to
control discussion ostensibly to prevent
the distribution of misinformation
now how have they chosen to do that in
this case they have chosen to simply
utilize the recommendations of the who
and the cdc
and apply them as if they are synonymous
with scientific truth
problem
even at their best the who and cdc are
not scientific entities they are
entities that are
about public health
and public health has this
whether it's right or not and i believe
i disagree with it but
it has this
uh self-assigned
right
to
lie
that comes from the fact that there is
game theory that works against for
example a successful vaccination
campaign
that
if everybody else takes a vaccine and
therefore the herd becomes immune
through vaccination
and you decide not to take a vaccine
then you benefit from the immunity of
the herd without having taken the risk
so people who do best are the people who
opt out that's a hazard and the who and
cdc cdcs public health entities
effectively
oversimplify stories in order that that
game theory does not cause a predictable
tragedy of the commons
with that said once that right to lie
exists then it finds out sir it turns
out to serve the interests of for
example pharmaceutical companies which
have emergency use authorizations that
require that there not be a safe and
effective treatment and have immunity
from liability for harms caused by their
product
so that's a recipe for disaster right
you don't need to be a sophisticated uh
thinker about complex systems to see the
hazard of immunizing
a company
from the harm of its own product at the
same time that that product can only
exist in the market if some other
product that works better
somehow fails to be noticed
so somehow youtube is doing the bidding
of merck and others
whether it knows that that's what it's
doing i have no idea i think this may be
another case of an autopilot
that thinks it's doing the right thing
because it's parroting the
corrupt wisdom of the who and the cdc
but the who and the cdc have been wrong
again and again in this pandemic and the
irony here is that with youtube coming
after me
well my channel has been right where the
who and cdc have been wrong consistently
over the whole pandemic so
how is it that youtube is censoring us
because the who and cdc disagree with us
when in fact in past disagreements we've
been right and they've been wrong
there's so much to talk about here so
i've heard this many times actually
on the inside of youtube
and with colleagues that i've talked
about talked with
is
they kind of in a very casual way say
their
job is simply to slow or prevent the
spread of misinformation
and they say like that's an easy thing
to do
like to know what is true or not
is an easy thing to do
and so from the youtube perspective
i think
they basically outsource
of
of the the task of knowing what is true
or not
to public institutions that on a basic
google search
claim to be the arbiters of truth
so
if you were youtube
who are
exceptionally profitable and
exceptionally powerful in terms of uh
controlling what people get to see or
not
what would you do would you take a stand
a public stand against the whole who cdc
or would you
instead say you know what let's open the
damn and let any video on anything fly
what do you what do you do here if you
say you were put if brett weinstein was
put in charge
of youtube for a month
in this most critical of times where
youtube actually has incredible amounts
of power to educate the populous
uh to give power of knowledge to the
populace
such that they can reform institutions
what would you do how would you run
youtube
well unfortunately
or fortunately this is actually quite
simple
the founders the american founders
settled on a counter-intuitive
formulation
that people should be free to say
anything they should be free from
the government blocking them from doing
so
they did not imagine that in formulating
that right that most of what was said
would be of high quality nor did they
imagine it would be free of harmful
things what they correctly reasoned was
that the benefit of leaving
everything so it can be said exceeds the
cost which everyone understands to be
substantial
what i would say is they could not have
anticipated
the
impact the centrality of platforms like
youtube facebook twitter etc
if they had they would not have limited
the first amendment as they did they
clearly understood that the power of the
federal government was so great
that
it needed to be limited by granting
explicitly the right of citizens to say
anything
in fact
youtube twitter facebook may be more
powerful in this moment than the federal
government of their worst nightmares
could have been the power that these
entities have to control
thought and to shift civilization is so
great that we need to have those same
protections it doesn't mean that harmful
things won't be said but it means that
nothing has changed about
the cost-benefit analysis of building
the right to censor so if i were running
youtube
the limit of what should be allowed is
the limit of the law
right if what you are doing is legal
then it should not be youtube's place to
limit what gets said or who gets to hear
it that is between speakers and audience
will harm come from that of course it
will but will net harm come from it no i
don't believe it will i believe that
allowing everything to be said does
allow a process in which better ideas do
come to the fore and win out so you
believe that in the end
when there's complete freedom to share
ideas
that truth will win out
so what i've noticed just as a brief
side comment
that
certain things become viral
irregardless of their truth
i i've noticed that things that are
dramatic
and or funny like things that become
memes
are not don't have to be grounded in
truth and so that what worries me there
is that we basically
maximize for drama versus maximize for
truth in a system where everything is
free
and that's worrying in the time of
emergency
well yes it's all worrying in time of
emergency to be sure but i want you to
notice that what you've happened on is
actually an analog for a much deeper and
older problem
human beings are the
we are not a blank slate but we are the
blankest slate that nature has ever
devised and there's a reason for that
right it's where our flexibility comes
from
we have effectively we are robots in
which the
a large fraction of the cognitive
capacity has been
or of the behavioral capacity has been
offloaded to the software layer which
gets written and rewritten over
evolutionary time
that
means effectively that much of what we
are in fact the important part of what
we are is housed in the in the cultural
layer and the conscious layer and not in
the hardware hard coding layer
that layer is prone to make errors right
and anybody who's watched a child grow
up knows that children make absurd
errors all the time right that's part of
the process as we were discussing
earlier
it is also true that as you look across
a
field of people discussing things a lot
of what is said is pure nonsense it's
garbage
but the tendency of garbage to
emerge and even to spread in the short
term
does not say that over the long term
what sticks is not
the valuable ideas so there's a high
tendency for
uh novelty to be created in the cultural
space but there's also a high tendency
for it to go extinct and you have to
keep that in mind it's not like the
genome right everything is happening at
a much higher rate things are being
created they're being destroyed and i
can't say that you know i mean obviously
we've seen totalitarianism arise many
times and it's very destructive each
time it does so it's not like hey
freedom to come up with any idea you
want hasn't produced a whole lot of
carnage but the question is over time
does it produce
more open fairer more decent societies
and i believe that it does i can't prove
it but that does seem to be the pattern
i i believe so as well the thing is in
the short term
freedom of speech
absolute freedom of speech can be quite
destructive
but
you
nevertheless have to hold on to that
because in the long term
i think you and i guess are optimistic
in the sense that
good ideas will win out
i don't know
how strongly i believe that it will work
but i will say i haven't heard a better
idea
yeah
i would also point out that there's
something very significant in this
question of
the hubris involved in imagining that
you're going to improve the discussion
by censoring
which is the majority of
concepts at the fringe
are nonsense
that's automatic
but
the
heterodoxy at the fringe which is
indistinguishable at the beginning from
the nonsense ideas is the key to
progress
so if you decide hey the fringe is 99
garbage let's just get rid of it right
hey that's a strong win we're getting
rid of 99 garbage for one percent
something or other and the point is yeah
but that one percent something rather is
the key you're throwing out the key
and so that's what youtube is doing
frankly i think at the point that it
started censoring my channel
you know in the immediate aftermath of
this major reversal of la for lab league
it should have looked at itself and said
well what the hell are we doing who are
we sensory we're sensory somebody who
was just right
right in a conflict with the very same
people on whose behalf we are now
censoring right that should have caused
them to wake up so you said one approach
if you were on youtube was just
basically
let all videos go that do not violate
the law well i should fix that okay i
believe that that is the basic principle
eric makes an excellent point about the
distinction between ideas and personal
attacks doxing these other things so i
agree there's no value in allowing
people to destroy each other's lives
even if there's a technical legal
defense for it now how you draw that
line i don't know
but
you know what i'm talking about is yes
people should be free to traffic and bad
ideas and they should be free to expose
that the ideas are bad and hopefully
that process results in better ideas
winning out yeah there's an interesting
line between
you know like uh ideas like the earth is
flat which i believe you should not
censor
and then like you start to encroach on
like personal attacks
so not not you know doxxing yes but like
not even getting to that like there's a
certain point where it's like
that's no longer ideas that's more
that's somehow not productive even if
it's
it feels like uh believing the earth is
flat it's somehow productive because
maybe this tiny percent chance it is
you know like it just feels like
personal attacks
it doesn't um well you know it's i'm
torn on this because
there's [ __ ] in this world there's
fraudulent people in this world so
sometimes personal attacks are useful to
reveal that
um but there's a line you can cross
like there's a comedy where people make
fun of others i think that's amazing
that's very powerful and that's very
useful even if it's painful but then
there's like once it gets to be
um
yeah there's a certain line it's a gray
area where you cross where it's no
longer
in any possible world productive
and that's a really weird gray area for
youtube to operate in and it feels like
should be a crowd source
thing or people vote on it but then
again do you trust the majority to vote
on what is crossing the line and not
i mean this is where
this is really interesting
on this particular like the scientific
aspect of this do you think youtube
should take more of a stance
not censoring but
to actually have scientists within
youtube having these kinds of
discussions and then be able to almost
speak out in a transparent way this is
what we're going to let this video stand
but here's all these other opinions
almost like take a more active role in
its recommendation system
in trying to present a full picture to
you right now they're not and they're
the recommender systems are not human
fine-tuned
they're all based on how you click and
there's this clustering algorithms
they're not taking an active role on
giving you the full spectrum of ideas in
the space of science they just censor or
not
well
at the moment it's going to be pretty
hard to compel me that these people
should be trusted with any sort of
curation or comment on matters of
evidence because they have demonstrated
that they are incapable of doing it well
um
you could make such an argument and i
guess i'm open to the idea of
institutions
that would look something like youtube
that would be capable of offering
something valuable i mean and you know
even just the fact of them literally
curating things and putting some videos
next to others
you know implies something
so yeah there's a question to be
answered but at the moment no
at the moment what it is doing is quite
literally putting not only individual
humans in tremendous jeopardy by
censoring discussion of useful tools and
making tools that are
more hazardous than has been
acknowledged seems safe
right but it is also placing humanity in
danger of a permanent relationship with
this pathogen i cannot emphasize enough
how expensive that is it's effectively
incalculable if the relationship becomes
permanent the number of people who will
ultimately
suffer and die from it is indefinitely
large
yeah there's uh currently the algorithm
is very rabbit hole driven meaning
if you uh if you click on the
flat earth videos
that's all you're going to be presented
with
and you're not going to be nicely
presented with arguments against the
flat earth and the flip side of that
if you watch like quantum mechanics
videos or no general relativity videos
it's very rare you're going to get a
recommendation have you considered the
earth as flat and i think you should
have both
uh same with vaccine
videos that present the power and
incredible
like biology genetics biology about the
vaccine you're rarely going to get
videos
from
well-respected
scientific minds presenting possible
dangers of vaccine and the vice versa is
true as well
which is
if you're looking at the dangers of the
vaccine on youtube
you're not going to get the highest
quality of videos recommended to you and
i'm not talking about like manually
inserted cdc videos that are like
the most untrustworthy things you can
possibly watch about how everybody
should take the vaccine it's the safest
thing ever no it's about incredible
again mit colleagues of mine incredible
biologists biologists that
talk about the the the details of how
the
mrna vaccines work and all those kinds
of things i think
maybe this is me
with the ai hat on
is i think the algorithm can fix a lot
of this and youtube should build better
algorithms and trust that
to and coupled with complete freedom of
speech
to expand
the
what people are able to think about
present always varied views not balanced
in some artificial way
hard-coded way but balanced in a way
that's crowdsourced i think that's an
algorithm problem that can be solved
because then you can delegate it to the
algorithm as opposed to this hard code
censorship of basically
creating artificial boundaries on what
can and can't be discussed instead
creating a full spectrum of exploration
that can be done and trusting the
intelligence of people to do the
exploration
well there's there's a lot there i would
say we have to keep in mind that we're
talking about a
um
a publicly held company with
shareholders and obligations to them and
that that may make it impossible and i
remember
um
many years ago back in the early days of
google
i remember a sense of terror
at the loss of general search
right it used to be that the that google
if you searched came up with the same
thing for everyone and then it got
personalized and for a while it was
possible to turn off the personalization
which was still not great because if
everybody else is looking at a
personalized search and you can tune in
to one that isn't personalized
what are you know
that doesn't tell you why the world is
sounding the way it is but nonetheless
it was at least an option and then that
vanished and
the problem is i think this is literally
deranging us
that in effect
i mean what you're describing is
unthinkable it is unthinkable that in
the face of a campaign to vaccine
vaccinate people in order to reach herd
immunity
that um
youtube would give you
videos on hazards of vaccines
when this is you know how hazardous the
vaccines are is an unsettled question
why is it unthinkable that doesn't make
any sense for from a company perspective
if intelligent people
in large amounts
are open-minded and are thinking through
the the the hazards and the benefits of
a vaccine
a company should
should find the best videos
to present
what people are thinking about well
let's come up with a hypothetical okay
let's come up with a
a very deadly disease for which there's
a vaccine that is very safe though not
perfectly safe
and
we are then faced with youtube trying to
figure out what to do for somebody
searching on vaccine safety
suppose it is necessary in order to
drive the pathogen to extinction
something like smallpox
that people get on board with the
vaccine
but there's a tiny fringe of people who
thinks that the vaccine is a
mind control agent
right
so should youtube
direct people to the only claims against
this vaccine which is that it's a mind
control agent
when in fact uh the
vaccine is
very safe whatever that means
if that were the actual configuration of
the puzzle then youtube would be doing
active harm pointing you to
um this other
video potentially now yes i would love
to live in a world where people
are up to the challenge of sorting that
out but my basic point would be
if it's an evidentiary question and
there's essentially no evidence that the
vaccine is a mind control agent and
there's plenty of evidence that the
vaccine is safe then
well you look for this video we're going
to give you this one puts it on a par
right so for the mind that's tracking
how much
uh thought is there behind it's safe
versus how much thought is there behind
it's a mind control agent will result in
artificially
elevating this now in the current case
what we've seen is not this at all we
have seen evidence obscured in order to
create a false story about safety and we
saw the inverse with ivermectin
we saw a campaign to portray the drug as
um
more dangerous and less effective than
the evidence clearly suggested it was so
we're not talking about a comparable
thing but i guess my point is the
algorithmic solution that you point to
um
creates a problem of its own which is
that it means that the way to get
exposure is to generate something fringy
if you're the only thing on some fringe
then suddenly youtube would be
recommending those things and that's
that's obviously a gameable system at
best yeah but the solution to that i
know you're
you're creating a thought experiment
maybe playing a little bit of a devil's
advocate
i think the solution to that is not to
uh limit the algorithm in the case of
the super deadly virus it's for the
scientists to step up and become better
communicators more charismatic is
fight the battle of ideas
so to create better videos you know the
like if the virus is truly deadly you
have a lot more ammunition a lot more
data a lot more material to work with in
terms of communicating with the public
so be better at communicating and stop
being
you have to start trusting the
intelligence of people and also being
transparent and playing the game of the
internet which is like
what is the internet hungry for i
believe authenticity
stop looking like you're full of [ __ ]
it's the scientific community if there's
any
flaw that i currently see especially the
people that are in public office
that like anthony fauci they look like
they're full of [ __ ] and i know they're
brilliant
why don't they look more authentic so
they're losing that game and i think a
lot of people observing this entire
system now
younger scientists are seeing this
and saying
okay if i want to continue being a
scientist in the public eye and i want
to be effective at my job
i'm going to have to be a lot more
authentic so they're learning the lesson
this evolutionary system is working
uh
so is there's just a younger generation
of minds coming up that i think will do
a much better job in this battle of
ideas that when the
when the much more dangerous virus comes
along they'll be able to be better
communicators at least that's the hope
the the using the algorithm to control
that is uh
i feel like is a big problem so you're
going to have the same problem with a
deadly virus as with the current virus
if you let youtube draw hard
lines
by the pr and the marketing people
versus the broad community of scientists
well in some sense you're you're uh
suggesting something that's close akin
to what i was saying about you know
freedom of expression ultimately
uh provides an advantage to to better
ideas so i'm i'm in agreement broadly
speaking
but i would also say there's probably
some sort of you know let's imagine the
world that you propose where youtube
shows you the alternative point of view
that has the problem that i suggest but
one thing you could do is you could give
us the tools to understand what we're
looking at
right you could give us so first of all
there's something
i think
myopic solipsistic narcissistic about a
an algorithm that serves shareholders by
showing you what you want to see rather
than what you need to know right that's
the distinction is flattering you you
know playing to your blind spot is
something that algorithm will figure out
but it's not healthy for us all to have
google playing to our blind spot it's
very very dangerous so
what i really want
is
analytics that allow me or maybe options
and analytics the options should allow
me to see
what
alternative perspectives are being
explored right so here's the thing i'm
searching and it leads me down this road
right let's let's say it's ivermectin
okay i find all of this evidence that
ivermectin works i find all of these
discussions and people talk about
various protocols and this and that and
then i could say
all right
what is the other side and i could see
who is searching not as individuals but
what demographics are searching
alternatives and maybe you could even
combine it with something reddit like
where
effectively let's say that there was a
position that
i don't know that
that a vaccine is a mind control device
and you could have a
steel man this argument
a competition effectively and the better
answers that steel mounted as well as
possible would rise to the top and so
you could read the top three or four
explanations about why this really
credibly is a mind control
uh
product and you can say well that
doesn't really add up i can check these
three things myself and they can't
possibly be right
right and you could dismiss it and then
as an argument that was credible let's
say
plate tectonics before that was an
accepted concept
you'd say wait a minute
there is evidence
for plate tectonic as crazy as it sounds
that the continents are floating around
on liquid
actually that's not so implausible you
know we've got these subduction zones
we've got a geology that is compatible
we've got puzzle piece continents that
seem to fit together wow that's a
surprising amount of evidence for that
position so i'm going to file some
bayesian probability with it that's
updated for the fact that actually the
steel man argument is better than i was
expecting right so i could imagine
something like that where
a i would love the search to be
indifferent to who's searching right the
the solipsistic thing is too dangerous
so the search could be general so we
would all get a sense for what everybody
else was seeing too
and then some layer that didn't have
anything to do with what youtube points
you to or not but allowed you to see
you know the general
pattern of
adherence to searching for
information and again a layer in which
those things could be defended so you
could hear what a good argument sounded
right like rather than just hear a
caricatured argument yeah and also
reward people
creators
that have demonstrated like a track
record of open-mindedness and
correctness correctness as much as it
can be measured over a long term
and sort of
i mean
a lot of this maps to
incentivizing
good long-term behavior not immediate
kind of dopamine rush
kind of
signals
i think ultimately the algorithm
on the individual level
should optimize for personal growth
long-term happiness
just growth intellectually growth in
terms of lifestyle personally and so on
as opposed to
immediate
uh i think that's going to build a
better society not even just like truth
because i think truth is a complicated
thing
it's more just you growing as a person
exploring the space of ideas
changing your mind often increasing the
level to which you're open-minded the
knowledge base you're operating from
uh the willingness to
empathize with others all those kinds of
things the algorithm should optimize for
like creating a better human at the
individual level
that you're all i think that's a great
business model because the person
that's using this
tool
will then be happier with themselves for
having used it and will be a lifelong
quote-unquote customer i think it's a
great business model
to make a happy open-minded
knowledgeable better human being it's a
terrible business model
under the current system
what you want is to build the system in
which it is a great business model why
is it a terrible model uh because it
will be decimated by
those who play to the short term
i don't think so
why well i mean i think we're living it
we're living it
well no because if if you have the
alternative that presents itself
it it it points out the
emperor has no clothes i mean it points
out that youtube is operating in this
way twitter is operating in this way so
facebook is operating in this way how
long term would you like the wisdom to
to prove that
well
even though a week is better what's
currently happening right but the
problem is you know if a week loses out
to an hour right
and
i don't think he loses out he loses out
in the short term that's my point is
you're a great communicator and you
basically say
look here's the metrics and a lot of it
is like how people actually feel
like this this is what people experience
with social media
they look back at the previous month and
say
i felt shitty and a lot of days because
of social media right like
if you look back at the previous few
weeks and say
wow i'm a better person because that
month happened
that's they immediately choose the
product that's going to lead to that
that's what love for products looks like
if you if you love like a lot of people
love their tesla car
like that's or iphone or like beautiful
design that's what love looks like you
look back i'm a better person for having
used this thing well you got to ask
yourself the question though if this is
such a great business model why isn't it
evolving
why don't we see it
honestly it's competence it's like
people are just it's not it's not easy
to build
new
it's not easy to build
products tools systems on new ideas it's
kind of a new idea we've gone through
this
everything we're seeing now
comes from the ideas of the initial
birth of the internet and there just
needs to be new sets of tools that are
uh incentivizing long term personal
growth and happiness that's it right but
but what we have is a market that
doesn't favor this right i mean for one
thing you know we had an alternative to
facebook
right that looked you know you owned
your own data it wasn't exploitative
and
facebook bought a huge interest in it
and it died i mean who do you know who's
on diaspora
the execution there was not good right
but it could have gotten better right
i don't think that
the argument that why hasn't somebody
done it a good argument for it's not
going to completely destroy all of
twitter and facebook when somebody does
it
or twitter will catch up and pivot to to
the algorithm this is not what this is
not what i'm saying there's obviously
great ideas that remain unexplored
because nobody has gotten to the
foothill that would allow you to explore
them that's true but you know an
internet that was non-predatory is an
obvious idea and many of us know that we
want it and many of us have seen
prototypes of it and we don't move
because there's no audience there so the
network effects cause you to stay with
the predatory internet
um but
let me just
i wasn't kidding about build the system
in which your idea is a great business
plan
um so
in our upcoming book heather and i in
our last chapter explore something
called the fourth frontier and fourth
frontier has to do with sort of a 2.0
version of civilization which we freely
admit we can't tell you very much about
it's something that would have to be we
would have to prototype our way there we
would have to effectively navigate our
way there but the result would be very
much like what you're describing it
would be something that effectively
liberates humans meaningfully and most
importantly it has to feel like growth
without depending on growth
in other words human beings are
creatures that like every other creature
is effectively looking for growth right
we are looking for underexploited or
unexploited opportunities and when we
find them
our ancestors for example if they
happened into a new valley that was
unexplored by people
their population would grow until it had
carrying capacity so there would be this
great feeling of there's abundance until
you hit carrying capacity which is
inevitable and then zero-sum dynamics
would set in
so in order for human beings to flourish
long term the way to get there is to
satisfy the desire for growth without
hooking it to actual growth which only
moves in fits and starts
and this is actually i believe the key
to avoiding these you know spasms of
human tragedy when in the absence of
growth people do uh something that
causes their population to experience
growth which is they go and
make war on or commit genocide against
some other population which is something
we obviously have to stop
by the way this is uh
a hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century co-authored that's right with
your wife heather being released to
september i believe you said you're
going to do a little bit of a preview
videos on each chapter leading up to the
release so i'm i'm looking forward to
the last chapter the
as well as well as all the the previous
one i have a few questions on that so
you you have um you generally have faith
to clarify that technology could be the
thing
that
empowers
this kind of future
well if you just let technology
evolve
it's going to be our undoing
right
one of the things that i um fault my
libertarian friends for is this faith
that the market is going to find
solutions without destroying us and my
sense is i'm a very strong believer in
markets right i believe in their power
even above
some market fundamentalists but what i
don't believe
is that
they should be allowed to plot our
course
right markets are very good at figuring
out how to do things
they are not good at all about figuring
out what we should do right what we
should want we have to tell markets what
we want and then they can tell us how to
do it best and if we adopted that kind
of
pro market but in a context where it's
not steering where human well-being is
actually the driver
we can do
remarkable things and the technology
that emerges would naturally be
enhancing of human well-being perfectly
so no but overwhelmingly so but at the
moment markets are finding our every
defect of character and exploiting them
and making huge profits and making us
worse to each other in the process
you